hey what is up guys I'm Kip EHD here and
the moto Z came out a few days ago we
had the Moto X before and I don't know
what Moto Y is but I think the gap is
actually appropriate because Moto Z is a
totally different phone than anything
we've seen from Motorola or Lenovo in
the past and I like a lot of it so
here's what's up moto Z is a high-end
flagship speck Android phone and it's
actually two phones
there's the Moto Z and the Moto Z force
so moto Z is the thinner prettier
version of the flagship five point two
millimeters thin 2600 milliamp hour
battery gorilla glass on the front and
the back and a 13 megapixel camera and
Moto Z force is a slightly thicker
version so it's two millimeters thicker
and it gets a shatterproof display a
3,500 milliamp hour battery and a 21
megapixel camera so right off the bat
the Moto Z force is a bit more expensive
but it's probably worth it unfortunately
these are also both exclusive to Verizon
right now the unlocked versions are
coming later I hate carrier exclusives
I've talked about that in the past but
what can you do that's just the way it
is with these so my favorite thing about
this phone is actually the build quality
all metal and glass no chassis flex or
any creaking of any kind tight
tolerances materially this could be one
of the best moto phones ever built and
obviously they've built a lot of good
phones and also do you think it looks
pretty good in black and that's just my
opinion but obviously that's pretty
subjective but there's no arguing that
this guy is well built and as a result
it feels great to hold and carry it's
really solid there's a microSD card slot
up top for expandable storage which is
awesome and a single USB type-c port at
the bottom which is an interesting
choice but maybe a bit premature I don't
think this is a phone where you have to
get rid of the headphone jack but they
did anyway using the phone I slowly got
used to it thanks to just attaching a
USB C to headphone jack adapter to my
headphones all the time it comes in the
box and I also use Bluetooth audio a bit
more but yeah of course I still miss
that headphone jack a lot the buttons on
the phone are clicky and everything but
they're a bit of a stretch with the
volume buttons all the way at the top
corner I mean I have big hands so even
for me it's a stretch which means if you
have smaller hands it's probably a bit
of a pain to reach them the other side
of the phone is blank so they could have
put the volume buttons over there on the
left or put them below the power buttons
like most other phones but I'd say maybe
the worst thing about this phone is that
it's a pretty constant fingerprint
magnet and it definitely doesn't look
good with fingerprints so if you hate
them as much as I do you can either grab
a D brand skin for it which leaves the
pins at the bottom exposed and wipes out
the fingerprints completely which is
great I'll link it below or you can grab
a color swap piece from Motorola they're
a little more expensive but they're
weightier to put on and take off and
I'll talk about them more in a second in
this video so aside from the frustrating
buttons and I guess maybe the lack of
water resistance moto Z is built great
on the front you have a fingerprint
reader in this square that kind of
doesn't match with the rest of the
aesthetics on the front of the phone but
it's fast and it works well so I'm not
complaining that it's there and you can
long press to read your finger and wake
up and then while it's on you can long
press again to sleep it's not actually a
home button no matter how many times you
accidentally try and the screen we're
looking at on the front is a 5.5 inch
quad HD AMOLED display again very good
really high pixel density obviously and
viewing angles are more than good enough
pretty wide and colors stay accurate it
doesn't get quite as bright as Samsung's
panels but most don't it's not the
easiest to see outdoors but other than
that the display on moto Z looks pretty
good and the software itself is Android
6.0 marshmallow right now with Moto's
very light customizations on top and a
lot of this is at least familiar to what
we've seen in other moto phones even if
the outside the package it comes in is
way different so you have you know your
screen off gestures your chop-chop to
turn the flashlight on and off and the
almost invaluable twisting twice to open
the camera for example those things
aren't going anywhere you almost get
used to them and miss them on other
phones and then the inside the UI itself
is still feeling a lot like stock
Android in the way it looks and feels
which is great I'm a fan of the clean
look and I like what they did to use a
lot of googles apps as their stock apps
this is something HTC did earlier so
even in the past there would be phones
that would look and feel like kind of
close to stock Android but they
use their own separate calculator and
dialer and photos apps and all these
things that Google already makes so now
with this phone you take a picture and
you swipe over and you're in Google
Photos right away the one and only
calculator app is the Google calculator
the one and only calendar app is the
Google calendar now obviously not
everyone's gonna notice or even care but
I think that's a really nice touch and
it kind of gets nullified by the fact
that it's a Verizon phone so now there's
also a bunch of Verizon bloatware in
there but you know it's the thought that
counts so aside from the Verizon
bloatware I'm a fan of the software
experience which means I'll probably be
really happy with the unlocked version
later this year I'm disappointed that
Motorola isn't fully committing to the
regular Google security updates like on
time for Android but I still think it'll
get upgraded to new versions of Android
faster than most phones and performances
you can probably already tell has been
smooth with my time with this device as
you would expect with a high-end device
with top-notch specs animations are
quick opening and closing and switching
between apps is quick it's snappy I got
pretty warm actually to the touch after
using it for a while or especially after
a long session of either web browsing or
gaming not to the point of any
performance issues but still something
to notice now the camera on the back of
this phone is another weird point for
the Moto Z first of all I can say that
cameras and smartphones has never really
been a strong point for Motorola it's
just true they've never really had the
top of the game smartphone cameras and
sadly that's still true with this camera
so here's the deal I did most of my
testing with the Moto Z force so 21 a
megapixel camera F 1.8 aperture optical
image stabilization dual LED flash and
for the most part the pictures looked
pretty decent especially in good
lighting it tends to overexpose a little
bit which leads to more blow and
highlights than lost shadows but that's
not a huge problem there's definitely a
lot more noticeable processing though
first of all you get a lot of sharpening
going on and there's also plenty of
noise reduction and when you combine
that you get some pretty soft or grainy
night shots depends on what you're
taking a picture of which in this kind
of an area the camera falls apart pretty
quick it is not good at night or in
low-light but look that's not like it's
not capable of taking great photos most
high-end smartphone cam
are capable of taking great photos but
when I say it's hit or miss that just
means it's a little bit more miss than
you would like it to be in your daily
phone but it can definitely hit if you
get it in the right conditions also if
you're just selfies the front-facing
camera is pretty decent it's a wide
angle it exposes well and it has a
front-facing LED flash which you don't
see every day the actual camera bump on
the back of this phone was pretty
interesting though because with the
thicker phone you would think they would
get rid of the camera hump but they
didn't the thicker moto Z force has the
exact same camera hump and that's
because it's probably the first phone to
ever have a camera hump with a purpose
it has a function to it it's for keeping
moto mods in place so moto mods our
Motorola's answer to the wave of modular
smartphones we've seen in the past year
so those pins you saw at the bottom of
the phone that's a combination of
magnets and smart connectors that let
the phone connect to a range of
accessories like the color swap back I
told you about earlier and wrapping
around the camera bump helps it hold in
place super well now I don't even know
if I'd call this stuff modular because
you're not really swapping anything or
taking anything off the phone but I'd
more just call moto mods modification
because it's easily the quickest and
easiest way to just add functionality to
a smart phone just by clicking it into
place you don't have to reboot the phone
you don't have to swap things in and out
there's no buttons there's no clicking
there's no rebooting it's just snap it
into place in two seconds and it's
secure and it fits and it works so here
are the mods we have now number one is
the color swap backs they just get rid
of the camera bump and changes a color /
material of the back of the phone the
battery backs these are a little bit
thicker and they snap on and they just
immediately start charging the phone the
JBL speaker which gets super loud way
louder than the phone's single front
facing speaker and also has a large
battery extension and even a little
kickstand and the projector which has a
built in battery for power and can
project whatever is on your smart phone
screen onto a wall or any projectable
surface so motor mods are actually
pretty awesome as they are now and we
can cross our fingers for more to come
since Motorola promises to try to make
them work with future Motorola phones as
well only problem is they're a little
bit expensive and it's hard to buy into
these with a promise of an ecosystem
especially
your next phone might just come from
Samsung or Apple or anyone else really
but I stand by that this is the best
execution of a smartphone mod that I
have ever seen also here's a million
dollar idea
a moto mod with a high quality DAC and a
headphone jack at the bottom and like a
little battery in there that would be
awesome you're welcome
I'll take 10% my favorite mod though
besides probably the color swap one is
definitely the battery because the
battery life of the existing moto Z and
Z force is really super average
obviously the Moto Z has a 2600 milliamp
hour battery that can only take you so
far with a big bright quad HD display
I'm not surprised I was only getting two
and a half hours of screen on time and
having to charge every single day didn't
shock me at all
moto Z force has a thirty five hundred
million power battery and again I'm
getting like three hours and change of
screen on time which for me is still
charging every night when I'm using the
phone with match brightness all day but
it's definitely like the battery mod is
the easiest way to just click it on it's
better than a battery case because you
don't have to like attach it around the
phone when you attach it to the phone it
starts charging immediately that's
pretty awesome so at the end of the day
moto Z is a great idea with great
execution but it's just not a complete
package like especially if you're
looking for a phone with a great battery
life or a great camera thing you're not
gonna find it here and you probably
won't buy this phone for that but a lot
of what they tried is awesome I'm glad
they did it thank you Lenovo / moto for
trying this and making moto mods work so
well and I do hope it works really well
and I do hope there are more third-party
moto mods from other companies that just
want to get in on this on the ground
floor because generation one it's pretty
damn good
so that's been it thank you for watching
I'll talk to you guys the next one peace